watch a movie investigator so I get a
display before I start off this is a
patient parchment and this purpose of
this market sells it is not an
architectural approach to the business
problem that we see quite the reason she
turning and so everyone is asking and
educator basis and today give you a
brief overview of it one of our better
take it not to components g20 wall of
scoring micro services and our
consolidate is hostile concepts in the
context of actual SWAT and the street
component with an advocacy
so which we okay
humming Iraqi okay okay so to start off
with she joining us for their
definitions a lot of us have a hotel for
me honey but this is my favorite one
it's the machine can learn through
experiences and then is the each there
two ways which we train machine to do
something one is unsupervised learning
so we have they already into the day of
unsupervised learning
that back and you're trying to identify
how people use their credit cards and
you want to [ __ ] it than certain
categories here on this area little
category from the name they say
beautiful he was by the online retailer
is identification into their patient
cetera and then there's a supervised
learning technique so for example human
given a smartphone Michael uses axial
data and then the human behavior the
number of his practices and so given all
the piece of chain once and were able
what activities in hitting explicitly
and then once he's done that a lot of
our classified or able to be absolutely
up without human intervention that has
an example blue white blue and in short
you exchange data set we invited women
to teach them sheep specifically what it
needs to do and this panel to be invited
us in to speak so for example property
used in thought affection impacting
actions but even that simple as
accepting the wants of the voice
and there are living means that this at
I feel like voting lead was the burning
and burning also conquered the drug is a
little cheaper if you use it as I didn't
think it would really go through these
steps in order to say to machine people
phone and the output of this process
will be inaudible and in any new war
scenario you would want to be sure of
the model we loop over time or it
retains its accuracy over time and then
once you have Islamic would love to who
the deployments and he would lose that
to score any huge idea that model and
this process is known as model for it
while the fluorine has amines like
objects you know it's it's defined as a
process of iterating methods based on
gatekeeper she trained model and it's
going to be used and assorted speak so
for example some of the common ones are
propensity story that is attention
fitting is going this opposite of our
users appreciation is a likelihood of a
customer could call your service and
stuff and works our competitor circuits
credit scoring that you go of a neat and
a nomination organized but we when we
talk about a story made up we were faced
with a number of challenges and it's not
the source asked for something like that
and those challenges can be mechanical
skate avidity so in a scientist should
be empowered with big data tools to
build model amount of data also since we
are not the ITO of class age masculine
data being generated in maybe different
formats license you should have a ID
skateable I think it then we get see the
data area for operations in the Atlanta
and Miami consistent should be dynamic
method it should be able to basically
respond to taken quest
I have effective a tall order mechanism
and identity to isolate hitter is
agnostic
so the devil that I'm going to show you
today I Roxy and I use the packing smart
site content offered and however we need
to some database no clothes as well so I
started out with the ESL in the CSV
format it was data with axial Dana CSV
format from very smart devices and then
I ran some a separate application to
inspire I thought about moving average
content and I quoted that means the CSV
file that would signal rk5 so I ran
these ETL animations using spot now able
to harness the processing capability
this part to really come together into a
much smaller data set which would then
be ready to explode type process is
excited run and then I use the random or
acquire to pacify me specifically
beginning it and then again equal value
to spiral fits across fabrication and
then finally I will say dismiss rate and
the output of this process would
basically threw [ __ ] on my clients that
I poi in two separate property vigils
and so you see I'm a fast now this is
the spy code now
in exactly one half with is release the
to overflow which will allow future
there will be movement my mind's
the old wonders of our models who have a
parabola to me and the point is one was
in the cloud and then the talk about the
jewels will be giving
this brings us to our next topic des as
microservices so essentially software
that microservices give us is going down
you won't pull one services so each of
these services can be deployed
independently and it won't even the
containers and they're isolated from my
heart so we're the of this what we call
a loosely coupled architecture as
opposed to be lighting up an
architecture paint benefits obvious but
on high levels you have a much ingenuity
golden scenery or the nyancy new
business capabilities so you know ideas
of individual routines can be
implemented without packing for a trip
and a wider mighty with every continent
the organization and since the
components are spread across multiple
servers and candies they can be said
about is really complements your
activities so the simple example didn't
stick with many of our anti-static work
with they happen that we can't have to
get in and they may want to use the ski
divinity okay manage this game pretty
good without but they want to keep the
next recovering my fiance so Microsoft
makers will get often and finally there
is another concept of the scalability
and neatness abilities imported water
rise you know there's a piece of the go
ahead
[Applause]
Hamilton itself providing a vision but
good luck division for Isis
so means a parabola welcome to today's
[Music]
that actually very smart rises and it
was to provide tailored content to the
user based on every gate here
so the Neumann architecture to nullify
this you have physical activity human
that gets backed by a smartphone it gets
translated into axial Gaeta and then I
had a bottle of Muhammad's to pacify
this axial data into activities and this
is what I call vegetable in sight so
either enemy to 88
with this era so it's vegetable
so this needs to be fed to another
bottle that was the husband of young
supervisor which customers similar users
together and generates equip it it is
good and he's armed about this is where
I collect will intelligently max will
take me for it right me 48 hours then
you get now take this information UT
pockets every together we did find out
that with certain acts or target content
based on the activity essentially this
architecture three micro services fix it
you can do it c'mon updates your machine
learning models and your monthly effect
in 200 data you can take it haha that's
is the advantage of this all right I say
and then you know you get because there
and then a lot not able to get skate
video so you have a scale or
classification and scale micro focuses
this with that for this particular
services and finally you need elite you
without free flow of data services for
which you need a consistent let's get a
little wallcovering event costing system
you get that from the piper smart okay
so now I'm going to talk about the
department or the species important part
before that this market is a
general-purpose computation for putting
this computer processing and it has a
white where I give out the agent such as
ETL being able to do ETL interactive way
and even if that's a live occipital
compensation money and speeding ian has
its all of among Egypt and all of this
one can't or programmatic promoting the
story in a sparkly grades within each or
instances and really important the
corner of a very acceptable open source
ecosystem and then in terms of Apix part
that also supports that positives or
negatives justanna hella
icon are etc so obviously he doesn't
engage air as part so or program is
as sequel electrons and then there's
this simple unification here that is
back with a I believe the guy for beta
into beta and that's our a debating time
and finally we have a speaker that is
our panelist off my tuition paperwork
and that gives you very high performance
for your history today over votes and
basically information these factors
allows you to build a people us to
Python skinny data with minimal
topically and as us through what people
are treating specific from competing the
iwi that is built on top of this part
sequel engine so if not we were able to
express your speaking or close in entire
- equal a direct sequel paper and not
gonna run your actuator is on top up on
top of your shady data that I can take
of sequel rates
exactly how they are taken for
communicator I never thought of memories
or improper cheating though it's or
resources in sync it's on the site be
news feed it's been data around me out
sorta system to be a tough message
busted its Papa pieces indicator bases
and then there's a lot of that about and
then there are a lot of screaming a
debate as an athlete said often even
Expedia's programmers have to make it
for their code such as exactly wants
guarantees
may be animating and one of that is
ordering bacon is about receiving
abstracted and users and you don't worry
about
but if we talk about doing machine
learning on scene here that are still
some limitations when it comes to soccer
team so number one is since we have to
write the models from scratch right we
thought would distract for sweetie a lot
of the models in spark and offered an
instigator did not supported it's not
ideal for continuous learning so if they
were constantly updating the models and
you can get a model you have to break
the stream down and then update them on
the seat back up the pump will be of a
peaceful solution for seeding data and
then so the ideal solution in that case
is just a service and I'll show you that
a solo this is a beautiful neighborhood
some books basically because it's a big
step and like you can see we have a star
cluster money I have to close my eyes
above the faculties to Busters and this
is the David's go vote similar to
Jupiter look but it's only for its part
underneath so essentially what I'm going
to do in this section is something to
classify the users activities so I have
speed data that is how many how many and
then I have this address I can see to us
it's headed money as Michael surrogates
for the past education for sure so in
this case I'm going to create my
considered my options so people who use
Martha Thomas the pump unit sold for
equity and essentially it's going to
take I'm gonna beat the scheme of the
data and this is gonna be accessing data
the user the model of the device and
then I'm going to use the Python if you
are now to get to to send this data is
located possibly cheating in and get an
output or get information not like a
service and that is going to be my
response to return that response back to
spot I'm going to register this and it's
going to be X I get on this penguin and
if I'm a lot of it or we find
now in order for me to actually start
reading indistinct events in this case I
have data on my s3 bucket that it's also
be speaking in it's like error so first
I need to have a subpoena
I can also ask Spartans an important to
speak up if I wanted to but in this case
I wanted to find the city must
specifically and it's very easy for you
to go over here it's really easy to go
from fat complication the state
occupation it's like if I am I to write
the same project with the mass
complication for me this data so I get
into JSON format but I have to say it's
marked up beforehand JSON provide the
schema and then go and give me his feet
because I hear this word if I need to
now go through the bachelor of scene III
work until TV for about we go for that I
think they start buckwheat stream and
that's how smart knows that it's going
to be a creator and not actress acting
they seem up it looks like I have
anything so they said there to handle is
a terrain park also has the data API so
this is what my favorite it looks like
if I go to explain its now if it was a
static data people will not take speed
initializing it would just display the
data a week since me it's been a bit of
a it's a it's a it's a speed up there we
can actually see the number of people
record it's not Rebecca's process and
it'll be back to data it basically did
the fire Raza ETL patients in this case
our cleanup and Sam and have time before
I effect on understand something on this
wave function to do that
wait straightforward and then I'm gonna
windows it whenever I talk about how I
know building although I feel it it's
infinite remove moving whistles to this
case it's surfacing weights forward or
at the same window
I have generally video they refinance so
we are gonna try to move streaming
application this cutoff I got to do
support stream and then he wants to an
operator so this is I can say that you
know I'm expecting Taylor to be 8 by 1
and then that is united to say with
water and sparkle on her head
it's the data of our contacts so now I
can integrate that data aggregated
unattended interval and I'm gonna
register that as a cable or people what
that means is that once I register this
is review it allowed me to see both
queries on top this here on top of the
street so I have this activity
recognition and now I can see within the
database over if is a sequel I can run a
sequel phrase about this detail so what
I do is I say select the x-axis and a
y-axis aggregated CX navigate the user
amount of ice that I needed to hear
created and that PL is calling for l2 I
got there is no microservice in response
table of pacification obvious in the air
and respond fast and here you can see on
this I have
he's also doing the instance
this so essentially when the response
Afghan gives you got sent to the
microservice and responsible so in this
case the same generation of this is the
user is going down now I actually see
what the activity how many users are
sitting
aging and then I'm gonna I need to send
this data back to another password users
together in real time so in order to do
that after I just write this data it out
to its pre visible at all and it just
call it that's exactly where to give it
water right to theta or FSA is right
screen in that way is for me right this
particular out so SP or any other sink
of your choice books here my second
notebooks so this is the part where I
actually come straight users together
so once I have the data and create
powered airplane that we do across
halfway society
I have never deviate where I create fire
and I take perhaps any user theater
let's eat what did activities aren't
inside
once I have this I can just feed this to
other you get and this is letting a
separate point for this different
identity and that Gutierrez the same
people to take this cost having a data
and feed it to another model and it's
going to get a response they should have
accomplished and we're ready to serve
this is you know we can get and now I
can on this on compliant bus or for you
so it is I create another view data data
and I can comment on the single rate
this we get consumers and essentially
right now yeah you start skating up
people desire
okay that's into my hospital I talk
about a lot of things so we sit
so for stealing on this labor services
he said databases and scenes and on fly
abused like my things acute cloud so I
got word this is yes the were exciting
different Kim fool around like four days
a week
this is their top people in matrix can
be accomplished with the King both
activity he does not operate minutes a
few happening or something like soup
interesting side of the doctor
so these are big numbers with pyramids
today which is about me in prison cell
Parvati was founded by the creators of
thank you spar buoy